[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my fabulous colleague
and friend the Jade warshaw getting the
polite golf clap from our studio
audience there like you hit a nice part
putt you know can very nice people out
there today I'm just going by Jade now
oh just Jade yeah just just the first
name only like Prince well I will say
this you have the personality you got
the Charisma and the name to pull that
off I don't if I just go by Ken
Ken I get the jokes Ken I am KU though
you are KU you see what I did there Ken
you see what I did there the Barbie
movie has ruined my name
forever uh but hey I digress the phone
number to jump in is 88255
2258 825 5225 and as I mentioned we do
have some folks joining us in the lobby
today and it's a great way to mention
that if you'd ever love to come watch
the show we come out couple times an
hour say hi take pictures sign books
tell jokes uh whatever it is and we have
uh free drinks in the form of coffee and
teas and things of that nature bake
Goods listen I'm going to start baking
some Goods so that they can get out
there in the lobby that's well I thought
you might bake a good for your co-host
and friend not today Ken no sampling of
food today not today but I'm speaking
the other part into existence but it's
blowing up on the Instagram at Jade
warshaw and occasionally she put they
put one on my feed at Ken Coleman on
Instagram uh but I will not be sampling
any food today unfortunately uh but the
good news is we will be coaching and
answering questions and John is going to
lead just off in Santa Barbara
California John how can we
help hey guys thanks for having me sure
what's going on well i' I've been
looking at paying off my
mortgage um but you know with the high
yield savings rates right now and having
that money earning interest for me it
just I I keep doing this dance of like
should I just pay it off should I put a
little bit more of like lump sums
towards it I've seen what you guys might
think towards this how much do you have
sitting there like how much is it going
to take in order for you to pay off your
mortgage if you were to uh I owe 280,000
on the mortgage and that's is that
exactly what you have in your high yield
or is it
more I I have 500 in my high yield let's
go way to go can I just ask a couple
questions how long did it take you to
save
that uh like probably 12 years wow
that's amazing um and what caused you
I'm just curious what caused you to save
that in a high yield savings account
because the rates haven't been what
they've been for 12 years or 10 years um
yeah I've haded in in like like low I'm
sorry like low cost index funds and
stuff but just over the the last couple
of years I've kind of moved some stuff
around and I needed to you know to buy
the house I had to like come up with a
down payment so that's kind of where it
all ended up right now sure okay so I'm
assuming there's no other debt it's just
your home
correct just my home correct okay um can
I ask real quick Jade what's your
Investment Portfolio look
like well I have I have it broken out
into two two different buckets I have my
retirement accounts which is
all uh like like lowcost index funds how
much in
there uh my retirement side is
565 cool cool fantastic how old are you
are you so that's I'm 48 way to go John
tell me about the other bucket so 565 in
retirement what what's the other bucket
how much in there the other bucket is my
high yield savings brokerage bucket that
you know when I bought the house my wife
oh you already gave us you already gave
us that number correct yeah yeah yeah
okay so you have over a million
dollars uh between the the retirement
and this high yield savings account mhm
and you owe two 80 on the
house that's correct listen if I'm you
tomorrow here's the thing I can tell
like you're this is the numbers guy
though like he's very he lowrisk he
likes very methodical like you can hear
that in the way you're speaking about
this even if you didn't have go ahead I
was just gonna say and the thing that
it's my interest rate on the house right
now is like 2.8 and I know everyone gets
excited about the tube like oh you've
got such a low interest rate you're nuts
if you want to pay that off keep that
and just keep and so that's listen 2% is
a great interest rate but 0% is better
so my thought here if I'm you even if
you didn't have the other money in
retirement by the way if you just were
like Jade I've got 500,000 in savings
what should I do I would tell you today
to pay off your home because here's the
thing and I my my screen says that it
says that maybe you could keep that
money in the high yield savings to keep
gaining interest but my thing is this
number one if you reach over and you pay
off that more mortgage number one you're
going to be free and there's there's a
calculation there that can't be
Quantified until you feel it right
because most of us have never felt what
it feels like to have a paid for home so
we really don't know the opportunity
cost there because we've not experienced
it so that's number one number two if
I'm thinking about this I'm going okay
if I pay off my mortgage today that
frees up what was my mortgage payment
what would it look like if I just took
that same mortgage payment plus whatever
other money and I'm dumping that into
whatever investment you choose I
probably wouldn't continue to put it
into a high yield savings account I'd
probably put it into other Investments
that are going to have a better rate of
return 10% 12% annualized I would do
that move because you're still going to
reap the benefits of Interest which is
really what you want to do and you're
going to have that peaceful feeling of
having a paid off Home
Mortgage right and I appreciate you guys
it's a it's a dance you do you know and
I I know that I've I I'm in a position
to do that and then it's you're always
like well if I do this or but then what
if I do that so it's always a
dance so I gotta ask you a question Jade
gave you great advice so we're past the
advice stage why'd you call were you
leaning one way or the other why'd you
call I I think I just wanted to hear
some perspective here yeah but which way
were you leaning which way are you
leaning to pay it off here here's the
good news matches up with my friend's
advice do it stop thinking about it and
the good news is this you're not locked
in like if you if you're like Jade I'm
I'm worried because if I take your away
I'm locked in no you're not if you if
you pay off your mortgage today John and
you're like man I hate this you want to
know what you can do go back and get
another mortgage if you just hate if you
hate the feeling of she did there that
was tricky J that was tricky I like that
but it is to know that and I I mean it's
funny to say it but it is good to know
that you can always go back when you
make these decisions like wait a minute
that wasn't good this is one of the few
financial decisions that you can
actually go back and say and undo it if
you don't like it let me throw one more
at you John how much is your house worth
if you sold it today give me a rough
estimate
1.5 bro so here's the deal wow if you
pay it off and you go man I want to get
a better you could sell that sucker and
and go wherever you want to go dude pay
this off that's what you wanted to do
Jade said you're right and I hate to
admit this she's kind of like my work
wife she's usually right listen she's
usually right I I'm usually right I
think you should do it I love
conversations like this when all roads
lead to Financial Freedom listen that's
called options sell it wow 1.5 mil my
guy he's doing 280 left go ahead my
friend that's a great investment that is
absolutely guaranteed great call hey
don't move she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken
Coleman and this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me and we are
here for you this hour8
825-5222
maybe trying to get a bigger shovel to
get through them faster love to take any
of those calls because I can tell you
this um your income is your greatest
wealth building tool so I'd love to help
out on any of those questions
8825 5225
88255 225 oh I just see it on the screen
and I want to go what is it your old
stomping grounds the Miami Florida area
is where we go next Matos is on the line
how can we help hello there how how you
how you guys doing today good what's
going on all right so I just have a
couple of questions um I work um I have
a job and I make around $87,000 per year
and my wife owns a marketing agency
company where she makes around $85,000
per year so basically our household
income is roughly 170 per year nice and
uh we do have uh some debt so I would
like to know how would you guys would
tackle this debt and I also have another
question which is how much money should
we save for taxes monthly for the
company cool um so let's start with
let's start with the taxes first so we
can actually think about what you'll
have left over for your debt so both of
you are self-employed I know you you
said your wife that was her business but
yours is your business as well right no
she's self-employed but I work for a
company I'm I'm actually a head of
support in my in the company right now
okay so if I were your wife my husband
and I we're also self-employed my
husband still is he runs our business
and um we always set aside 25 to 30%
every quarter it just it's part of his
business sheet and that's part of it it
just automatically goes out and 25 to
30% and that way it's like out of sight
out of mind you're not touching it and
then when it's time to uh file those
quarterly it's there ready and waiting
and we just and then we have a
bookkeeper that helps us with everything
else so I strongly strongly recommend
th those two practices having somebody
to help you with your books and you just
knowing every quarter you've got to set
aside x amount of dollars and making
sure as as much as you can making sure
that the money that you're paying
yourself in payroll is very steady that
you're not just pulling us pulling out
money for this and pulling out money for
that but deciding hey this is what we
pay ourselves out of her business and
it's consistent and that just makes it
easier um on everybody so that's my
first um piece of advice for your first
question does that make sense to you
yeah so basically just 25 to 30% uh for
uh monthly because it really fluctuates
the number of clients that we get so
it's possible that right now it's $7,000
per month but next month could be around
you know 10 to 12,000 12 yeah depends on
the the number of clients we get right
right set aside 25 to 30% monthly yeah
every month because whenever you're
receiving that money set that portion
aside because like you said every month
is different so rather than saying hey
every month I just put $700 aside that's
not going to work it's got to be based
off the income that you're actually
bringing in um and so that's that's what
I would do is this her first year in
business uh this is actually her second
year yeah I I would also I mean I think
Jade's right it's a good rule of thumb
but I think you've got something to work
off of and did you do your taxes
yourself or did you have a tax Pro do
these taxes on her business oh we we
have someone to do our texes yes well I
would also consult that text person and
and go okay based on last year and where
did we go did we pay too much did we
take too much out I mean do you recall
that the very first year was kind of
like was a break even year because we
had a lot of cost you know to play to
pay the employees and also the office
and no because we broke even the first
year yeah I think I think Jade gives a
great rule of thunb but I'd also be
Consulting that tax professional every
quarter you know start I'd say my point
is Jade gave you great advice start
there but I would also be watching that
because I I ran a as well as my wife and
I did and our account we were we were
checking in quarterly that's good but
watching sometimes it's more expensive
like you're paying for more of their
time so depending on what you're yeah I
think they're I think that's whatever
you you want to spend I think that's up
that's up to you but Ken makes a good
point in making sure that you're just
like make sure you're getting all of
your service out of them yeah I just
wanted to maximize the dollars so I
didn't want to hold back too much or
hold back too little that was the only
reason I was checking in and a lot of
times by the final quarter you're kind
of like okay it it starts you can start
to see you start dialing it in and and
two your point I think you make a good
point but we weren't spending a half day
or it was maybe one quick phone call
that's true it was not a heavy fee and
and so anyway that is a good point onto
the Deb so got that wrapped up uh
squared away okay so now with the debt
how much debt do you guys have okay so I
I wrote down three here so the credit
card debt is around
$66,000 and then we have a first
personal loan that is around $133,000 so
$600 monthly is our pay okay and then we
have a car loan for $13,000 and we pay
350 monthly so I would like to know if
on these two that we are paying monthly
should we just keep paying that or
should we increase the payment to to try
to get rid quicker what would you guys
say so the best way to to pay off debt
is to use what we call the debt snowball
method there's other methods out there
but this is really the best fastest most
motivating way so what we do there is we
pay minimum payments on everything right
you have to satisfy that minimum payment
so you're not laid or delinquent or
anything like that then you list the
debts that you have from smallest to
largest so in this case it sounds like
the credit cards are the smallest debt
that you have and so any money that you
have above and beyond those minimum
payments you throw it at One debt and
that's the smallest debt and you knock
it out as quickly as possible and then
when you knock that debt out it frees up
that minimum payment right that you put
along with your other margin and you
start throwing at the next smallest debt
so we're only paying off One debt at a
time as opposed to trying to you know
put a little here a little there a
little there does that make sense yeah
it does and so then you can move a lot
quicker that way and it's nice because
you kind of feel that that excitement of
when you pay off a debt you're like yes
I did it and now you want to go do
another one so that's what I would
say okay that's perfect that makes sense
hey real quick question on the car what
do you think that car is worth are you
upside down in it what's what's going on
with the car so basically this car was a
Corolla 2020 Corolla that we got and the
car actually appreciated because we got
in very good timing right so the car now
is worth around 18 to 177,000 I don't
even know if maybe is a good thing to
maybe sell the car what I want Jade to
weigh in on what do you think Jade do
you have is it your second car do you
already have another car or do you have
yeah this is the second car that's my
wife's car so I drive another car yeah
and other car you have is paid off no
it's lease it's a lease that I have and
it goes into oh you didn't mention that
you didn't mention the lease I'm sorry
listen if debt is money that you owe to
anyone for any reason for those of you
listening that's not to get on to you uh
matus but a lot of people they like I
don't have any debt just my student loan
and I'm like no that is debt okay so
tell us about this car lease right quick
uh so this one that's my car and it's
450 a month and it goes until June of
this year that's when I'm I'm done with
the car okay so in June of this year
you're out of that lease we're not
redoing it we're not that's it so are
you going to try to buy the car out like
what are you going to do what was your
plan to do at the end of that lease just
I should yeah just turn it in and try to
get something cheaper per month no no no
no not per month okay I'm glad that you
said this because we're getting to the
root of it the whole thing and this is
not just for you so don't think I'm
griping at you although I am griping at
you a little bit the point of this is to
create a new lifestyle because we can
never we can never solve a problem while
simultaneously creating it so if we say
I want to get out of debt like if that's
what you're shooting for then you have
to stop creating the problem meaning you
have to draw a line in the sand and say
I'm no longer borrowing money anymore if
debt is the problem I have to stop it
dead in its tracks So for anybody
listening not just Matos the first your
first order of business when you're
going to pay off debt is you say I'm not
borrowing money anymore that's it that's
how we live our life then after that you
can start to actually make changes that
will stick and that will actually solve
the problem so in Matteo's case he needs
to trade in that lease but since he
knows the time is coming in June he can
start saving up some cash here so that
when June comes he can just give back
that lease and say thank you for the
time I'll never do that again and but by
the way here's $5,000 I'd like to buy
that car over there in cash in the
feeling that he's going to feel a
freedom and just control is going to
outweigh everything Ken no more payments
I agree i' sell the car by the way the
$188,000 value that is rare that a car
goes up in value I'd get out of it now
get a decent little car get you a to z
for five grand this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsay show
thrilled that you're with us we're here
to help you win with your money in your
work and in your relationships those
three areas are completely connected and
if you're not winning in one I can tell
you you're losing in the others I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number to jump in is triple 8825 5225
before we get to our question of the day
uh my co-host uh wanted to add a little
something you had a little something I
did I wanted to clarify from the last
caller because he was saying that his
wife was self-employed and he wanted to
know how much to set aside you know for
taxes and so we were talking about it
but I don't think we clarified Ken that
the money that he's setting aside the 25
to 30% that he's setting aside every
month for the quarterly taxes that's of
his payroll it's not of everything that
the business brings in and so that's why
I was kind of saying if you can have
your payroll set as the same amount it
makes that a lot easier and I think
that's also what you were saying if it's
like you can reg you can regulate it a
little bit easier so that's right just a
Clarity it's your payroll not of the
whole the whole so there you go yeah
good stuff all right our question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services winter is rougher
in some areas of the country than others
but there are things that make sense to
do no matter where you live that's why
neighborly has a helpful winter
checklist that you can download for free
check it out at neighborly
tocom Ramsey today's question comes from
Naomi in Utah is it greedy or ambitious
for me to work towards reaching a
specific number goal of making $220,000
a month I work as an insurance broker we
are expecting a little boy in March and
we have 15,000 in debt I want to help my
family get out of the financial hole I
have put uh Us in with student loans and
help save for a house this is really
been weighing on me because I want to
help financially but I don't want to
become greedy if I am meeting this
monthly goal I love this question Ken do
you I think it's very straightforward I
love it so much but I think a lot of
people deal with this um and there's a
lot of angles we can talk about this
number one the answer is absolutely not
it makes you a woman who is loving her
family well that you want to step up and
pay off your debt and make sure that
life is good when baby boy arrives and
make sure that you're kind of pulling
your weight in your home like that's
great not all but is ambitious by the
way ambitious is great it's a great
quality to have because what I see with
this is you've got a very clear goal and
a very clear why and that kind of
ambition is fabulous and a good point to
add to that is and I want to say this
for anybody you you may have heard Dave
say this but and it's so true money does
money only makes you more of what you
already are like it's completely a moral
it's this it's it's nothing until you
add yourself to it right and so if
you're an ambitious person it just makes
you more Ambi ambitious right if that's
what makes you tick if you're generous
it makes you more generous if you're
stingy it makes you more stingy right if
you're you know so you just kind of have
to filter it through who you are and if
you start to notice qualities that you
don't like or the people around you are
appointing out qualities in you that you
don't like you have to really look take
a long look in the mirror and be like
okay this money like me earning more
money is starting to magnify a quality
that was always there I just didn't see
it before so that's teaching Point
number one Kenneth um oh dro the Kenneth
on me I thought I got in trouble listen
if I want if we really go I'm saying
Wayne I'm getting to the middle name but
um Ken I think that what she's saying
this goal of making 20,000 a month it is
ambitious I don't know what you make
currently so I don't know if this is
like a long ways away I don't know what
what it means for you to get to this
goal but I do want you to make um smart
goals fair enough so let's let's let's
really sit down and if if 20,000 is
really achievable and it's something
that you can you know get to and figure
out what your time frame is so let's get
very clear and specific about this goal
but I think it's a great thing Ely not
greedy I think it's your reason for
wanting to do this is a noble yeah I I
like teaching lesson number two um and
and here's what I would add to that
you've got to be careful that if you
make 5,000 a month right now and you set
a goal for 20 that can be a very
intimidating and very quickly
discouraging mountain to climb so to
your point it's like it's kind of like
going I know I need to lose 100 lb but
if my mindset is always on losing 100 lb
which is a long and difficult Journey
then there's a greater chance that I
fall off because it's just so dagam hard
which is why Dave was so brilliant by
coming up with baby steps that's right
he built in this idea of momentum
because I accomplished something that's
doable let's be honest for some people
$1,000 is difficult that's right so if
you're thinking about paying off
$380,000 all day long as opposed to
going no baby step one is and so this is
the IDE and that's why we talk about it
so just I loved your advice there and I
think that's the key because if you go
oh I got to make 20,000 and then month
three and month six you're not even
close you can start to feel like this is
impossible when it's not it's like okay
what do I need to do yeah to make 25%
more yeah yeah you got to break it into
those bite-sized chunks yeah so great
ADV I like all right uh to the phones we
go Christine is joining us and I think
this is uh cordelan I think it's you say
that that's right is that right
Christine did I say that right you did
good job well I'm Hooked on
Phonics oh no how could we help so my
husband and I have been considering
selling our
house um we relocated just over a year
ago up here um we were previously living
in Oregon realized we didn't want to
raise a family there moved here um
bought another this is our second house
we sold our first one um then my husband
got a job that was great paying but as
soon as it snowed he was laid off and
then it was for five months wow shoot so
with the work that he was doing and the
company he worked for he couldn't go
find a temporary job because they could
call him until late morning about 10:00
I think it was every single day they
could still call him into work and they
did every once in a while so he wasn't
able to go find work elsewhere that's
like a carrot dling it was it was not
fun so he doesn't work there anymore
yeah well and by the way real quick
lesson and I know you've learned this
but I do want to point this out he could
have left he could have left and he
should have left in the future if this
happens and I'm just talking to him
right now um he's listening in the other
room oh good good what's his name so I
can make this name is Daniel hey Daniel
you're a good man you're a hard worker
but this is something you need to learn
from never again let a situation like
that hold you hostage you got to go do
what you have to do to take care of you
and that amazing wife and so that's the
idea here don't ever don't ever let that
happen to you again you just go get busy
and and and we keep some income coming
in as much as possible and then we look
to level up so just a quick little that
that's a tough situation and it's a bit
man manipulative but that's not why you
called so Christine so so why are we
thinking we need to sell the house walk
us through this okay so we were preed
before we moved up here we were in baby
steps four five and six great okay so um
we were prepared for a layoff not
prepared for something that long um then
in April my husband had to have his
appendix removed oh yikes literally
right when you went back to work it was
great it was a time my gosh that's
horrible by the way I've had that
happened to me and that's not fun oh
that's horrible it was not fun yeah I've
been there done that so we um so now we
have about
$3,000 left of medical
bills um after that happened then my
husband realized I don't want to go work
for that company anymore so we quit we
started a small LLC where he was doing
material delivery some construction
things um with his brother okay which
was great it great at the time um but
fall was it um replacing the income
fully that he was making before it was
not fully replacing what he was supposed
to be getting from his previous employer
okay um there's a lot of things that
happened with that employer we ended up
paying $1,200 a month in insurance so
that really took a huge hit on us that
they told us they were going to work
with us so I wouldn't have to pay that
and then they didn't
so we lost that okay Christine so here's
where we're at that music means we have
to step aside pay some bills but we're
going to put you on hold okay because we
got to come back we got to get to the
bottom of this debt and why the house
may or may not be the best move forward
okay so you hang on and we'll be back
this is the ramsy show don't
[Music]
move
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mor AG home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a $5,000
seller guarantee gives your offer the
best chance of being accepted the home
buyer Edge from Churchill gives you an
advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me and as we
went into our last break uh we were
talking with Christine uh her husband's
on the uh phone in another room and uh
they have been through some ups and
downs lay off some stuff like that
they've gone through some medical stuff
and Jade is getting to the bottom of
where we are financially so we're going
to bring Christine back in So Christine
here's what I want you to do uh tell
Jade what your financial numbers are
just give us the just the facts and and
what you're trying to solve by maybe
selling the house right so we have a big
income problem our mortgage is
2150 a month um a month and then I in
our budget our bills um what we owe
comes to about $4,000 a month well what
I'd like for you to go through is list
out your debt what you owe like the
entire balance so for instance if I said
you say we have a car and we owe 14,000
or we have like go through all your
debts so I can kind of see how this is
we have only medical debt and um 100
yeah it's it's supposed to be 150 a
month is what we're supposed to be
paying
no no what you're supposed to be doing
sorry no go ahead I'm I'm reving I'm
revving up I'm revving up Christine what
you're supposed to be doing is paying
off the debt so we're never seeking to
have the lowest payment possible um
unless it's you know a debt snowball
situation and we're paying minimum
payments so if you're telling me the
only debt you guys have is this medical
debt yes and how much is it and it's
$3,000 so here's the income problem me
and no answer that question first yes
yes but I heard the income problem the
income problem is you're only making
$2,150 a month and I'm struggling wait
no no no that's the mor that's a
mortgage payment what are you making I'm
sorry I'm sorry what are you making we
are
making we are
making just under $3,000 right now okay
so I wasn't far off okay just under is
that 2500 or is that 2900 that's about
29 okay that's take home that is our
take home goodness gracious what how
who's doing what who's working we are we
are both working part
time
because I feel scared for my husband to
go back full time why we have two we
have two small children at home okay and
um last winner was not a good winner for
me because
of um moving to a new area not knowing
anybody okay alone I feel being alone
and then um when he would work he would
leave in like 400 a.m. and I have would
have no idea when he's coming home okay
so you've got some real trauma based on
that situation it was very uncomfortable
for you and so that fear is you're kind
of holding him back going I don't want
you to go I don't want you to leave me
here yes okay all right and why and and
and so why aren't you working
full-time um I don't I think because he
also doesn't want to be home full-time
because he wants to be the provider for
our family okay and I don't want to take
that away from him well you are how old
are your
kids one and a half in three and a half
okay yes so um real talk real talk real
talk when my husband and I moved here
from South Florida um it was very
difficult my husband works from home we
have two small kids similar to you and
we don't know anybody we didn't know
anybody we didn't have any friends and
I'm the one going into an office every
day so I get to be around people my
husband is talking to himself in his
office upstairs you know what I'm saying
like there's nobody there so I relate to
what you're saying there is a a
loneliness about that that is worth like
worth noting like I understand that but
it can't be to the point where you tell
this man he can't go go to work that's
just it you just have to realize
honestly Christine that you're in a
season and some Seasons suck and some
seasons are really hard but it truly is
just a season and it will get better and
it will start to open up and honestly by
you keeping him at home it's keeping you
from embracing That season and making
yourself get out there get to know
people learn the area figure out figure
out what your new normal is and I'm not
going to lie to you that's tough I'm
still trying to we over here warshaw are
still trying to figure out our new
normal and it's been a year and a half
and so I just want to don't worry we're
going to play pickle ball with Stacy and
and Sam we'll do some of those out hey
you know I just want you to know that
it's a real thing but don't let it hold
you back just embrace it and go this is
where we're at right now the good news
is you guys don't have a lot of debt and
it can be gone in a month if you guys
would just work
well Christine listen uh you've nailed
it you have an income problem not a debt
problem but you actually have a deeper
problem you've got some real trauma and
you've got some real fear and um you're
making this harder than it needs to be
so I understand how hard it was very
very understanding to what you went
through but what you guys are doing now
is making this thing way harder than it
needs to be and and let's just talk
about the mindset here Christine he
doesn't have to take another job that
has him leaving at 4 in the morning and
not you not knowing when he's coming
back right we got a false narrative
there bad experience what do we learn
from that not going to do that again not
good for Christine not at this season
with the littles so um hubs needs to get
a full-time job got to I mean and and if
he can't get it quickly he's got two
part-time jobs to equal fulltime and you
need to work and you guys are going to
be okay cuz let me tell you something if
there was a person on the planet who was
not ready to have three kids under the
age of three it was me and I survived it
if I can survive it not lose my mind
yeah then he can and so when you're
working he can handle it but we got to
figure this out because if you're going
you're going to lose your house like you
won't even have the choice which makes
it even worse so stop the bleeding
now stop the bleeding and it's a
Band-Aid and the Band-Aid is income that
simple you guys can pay off three Grand
in no time but it's time to work and and
you need to start channeling that fear
into some fuel to Say Never Again are we
going to get in this situation you guys
got to a point where you were in Babys
set four five and six that's to be
applauded and it can be repeated do you
understand Christine like it's time time
for you to be a big girl and for your
husband to be a big boy and we're not
going to let fear keep us paralyzed you
got
it yes sir all right Christine we love
you Christine we're pulling for you
sweet sweet sweet oh we had to give her
the the tough side the the the rocky
exterior yeah because here's what's
encouraging about that they have no
their de is so small, now I think they
went through their emergency fund which
I wanted to get you to weigh in on that
their thing one is keeping their house
like their thing one is keeping 100% but
do you agree that too many people rely
on the emergency fund when there's a job
loss as opposed to going no that's to
replace the HVAC I'm going to go work do
something I try to guard our emergency
fund like I'm the Archangel in front of
it I don't ever want to use it and I
don't think you should use it for job
replacement
I I'm going to say it like this like I
think that it is there for if you lose
your job because here's the thing it
might take a few minutes but it might
take a little minute if you're like hey
I had this wonderful corporate job I was
making 70,000 a year give you that how
how long is too long to use the
emergency fund
oh well here's what I wanted to say
you're always supplementing it with
something so you're going out and doing
some type of work until you find the
next work that's what I'm getting at so
like if you're I'm going to two and
three jobs to not use it yeah if you're
Contracting your own work a little bit
you're doing picking up some instacart
type stuff and it's it's supplementing
you but you need a little bit from the
emergency fund just to make it meet
little bit that I'm that's what it's
there for like I'm not going to mad at
someone for that I didn't know I was so
hardcore but I feel the sentiment of
that like I never want to I don't want
to touch it but I get it if you do I
don't want people to view it as a
failure when they have to use their
emergency fund for an emergency okay you
know what great point I don't want to
judge anybody that's done it I would
rather take on the older brother coach
rooll and go hey I I have always viewed
it as the HVAC that goes out in the mid
of winter and it's 8 Grand or 12 Grand I
don't look I go no no no no don't touch
it do it without well here's the deal if
I rely on the emergency fund it takes
away some of the
urgency to go get paid you're right
that's all I'm saying I'm not judging
I'm coaching I I think you're right Ken
we need to have that Ken Coleman mindset
there we go oh wow this is very exciting
hey Jade agrees with me I'm going to
take a break while I can this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
a
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money and in your
work and in your relationships the phone
number to jump in to get coached up is
aa825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman Jade warshaw
joins me this hour 88255 225 we'll take
your money questions Jade will lead you
through those
and if you got any work rated questions
hey I need a bigger shovel I need more
money um and I feel like maybe I'm
limited or I need some ideas you want to
start a business any of those type of
questions we both weigh in on those as
well so thrilled to have you with us
let's get this hour started with faith
in Cincinnati Ohio Faith how can we
help hi I'm fangirling a little bit I'm
so excited thank you well you got to
have faith you got to have faith the
faith the faith there it is look at that
that was seamless she didn't even know I
was going to do it Faith what's going
on so I recently
um stopped my business I guess or sold
it and I have all of my equipment which
I am now selling for
$3,000 um and I'm going to get the
$3,000 in a lump some tomorrow sweet
nice um I've been I've been following
the baby steps pretty religiously um by
the book and I'm on baby step number two
cool um So currently right now I have um
four credit cards total but my lowest is
600 and then 3,000 exactly okay so the
question comes in where um I'm going to
get this 3,000 tomorrow and I know
usually we go um you know first you pay
off the 600 and then you'll go on to the
3,000 um however since I am getting
exactly the 3,000 and the minimum pay
pay on the $3,000 credit card is $130
versus the $600 is only
$29 I was wondering if it would be
smarter to go ahead and pay off the
3,000 in full that way I have that extra
130 each month where I had paid that off
and then it would really help me pay the
$600 off quicker listen it's a $600
difference so the minimum payment is
based on what the balance is on the card
so if you pay off the $600 one first and
then you turn around and pay the rest on
the 3,000 one it's still going to knock
your your balance down to almost nothing
all but
$600 right so if we're splitting hairs
here which we are splitting hairs I
would still do it the correct way just
for the the feeling of like I'm done
with this one and now I'm going to the
next one and honestly what we're doing
here is we're we're teaching ourselves
to submit to a plan and a way of life
that's different from the way we always
done things and that's that's what's at
the Crux of why I'm telling you to do it
that way cuz I mean like I said we're
talking about two bills here Ken it's
not like we're talking about a long list
of debts and like I said it feels like
splitting hairs but there's something to
that that I think is worth noting of say
you know what there's a plan that I said
I was going to follow I'm just going to
submit to the plan and the plan says
smallest to largest I might have my
thoughts of thinking why it should be
different or why my situation could be
different but there is something to be
said for that practice of submitting to
a plan and doing it for the purposes
that the plan says which in this case is
to feel that quick win and the interest
doesn't have anything to do with it and
the monthly payment doesn't have
anything to do with it it's just those
quick wins piling up and so that's why I
would do it that
way awesome that sounds great thank you
guys so much you got it listen what I
want to clarify here listen if she goes
home and she's like listen I want to do
it that other way cuz I like that
Lightning's not going to strike her but
I just told her the I agree with you
it's still going to be she's still going
to have $600 to pay off one way or the
other it doesn't matter but but but I
will say I agree with you Jaden because
you could almost hear the psychology in
her voice as she was like if I pay off
the three I only have to do $29 a month
and that's the whole point when Dave
devys this thing yeah it's not the don't
give yourself this little out to go well
I only have 600 left on this but it's
only 29 a month so I could fudge here MH
and and that's why it's all mindset it's
all mindset so great advice there let's
go to Warren now in Houston Texas Warren
how can we
help hey man um so essentially in a note
show um my wife quit working um because
we decided it was going to be best and
we're going to try to make it work for
her to stay home and uh just try to live
off my income and um that income is
62,000 um she was registered n so that
that um income going away you know it
wasn't nothing obviously looking at a
pile of De and I'm just trying to get
out from under it and kind of
get how much was her
income when she was a registered nurse
how much did she make uh how much did
she bring home when she was a registered
nurse uh she was roughly $30 an hour um
you know so maybe right around the same
about 60,000 or so so you've taken a cut
of
50% essentially Okay so we've got about
a couple years ago been living off that
for a little while but like I said it
was a it was a hit okay so because we've
got about three minutes three and a half
minutes quickly layout for Jade what
your actual debt is smallest to
largest uh so the smallest would
probably be student loan
3,200 um my wife's car is about 5,300 my
truck about 8,000 left on the
Note um medical about 10 and I also have
an investment property um that's got
about 90,000 on it left okay and how
much is left on your personal mortgage
that's about 2,300 2,300 on the tractor
yes okay and then go back and tell me
sorry I talked over you the property
what do you owe on
it uh the investment property was 90,000
okay and then your personal mortgage
what do you owe on it just curious uh I
don't have a mortgage oh you guys are
renting no we own the house oh you own
it outright
great what's the investment property
worth um ballparking if I to guess
probably 120 if it was high on high
maybe 130 listen if I'm you I I don't
you could sell the investment property
but there's part of me that feels like
are you guys on a
budget um as far as what you're not on a
budget okay there's your answer General
J today budget yeah I've got so I got a
budgeting app that I've downloaded
recently and I started putting things
into that so yeah it's kind of started
to budget things out okay you're
starting to budget I'm happy to hear
that I hope that you're using the every
dollar budget because it truly is the
best way to budget but I think when I'm
looking at these numbers I'm going okay
the debt is not astronomical I really
truly think that you guys need a plan
for your money $60,000 you know 62,000
you're bringing in your highest debt is
a $10,000 medical debt you know and then
your truck is $18,000 the rest of that
makes it$ 18,000 the rest of it is just
little ankle biters so I I might be of
the mind of like is your proper is your
um property cash flowing or is it just
not really doing much it's it's cash
flowing it's about 6,000 a year so I
have a radical idea sell it it's radical
how long has the wife been
home uh about two years now so I have a
daughter that's two and I have a
relatively I got to tell you something
the hard conversation that I'm having
with my wife in this situation is go
back to work the kids will be fine it's
such a small amount of debt and if we
double our income you work the debt
snowball fast I know keep the income
property am I crazy Jay no that's right
on right I for a small amount of time
just to pay this split yeah so I I think
it's a tough conversation kids will be
fine you need that income that's the
fastest way RN come on it's either that
or get rid of the income property y
yikes this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the ramsy show America
where we help you win with your money in
your work and in your relationships I'm
Kim Coleman Jade warshaw joins me we are
here for youle 8825 5225 you want to get
coached up nothing to be scared of we're
going to take good care of you give you
some honest
uh coaching and cheer you onle 8825 5225
okay before we get back to the phones
Jade I I saw a headline the other day
and and I didn't dive in yeah but I know
you have and I know you've got an
opinion so so I am seeing that now in
our outrage
culture some student loan borrowers are
going I'm not going to pay I'm going to
protest wow yeah now it's one thing to
protest in the streets over a political
candidate I'm all for that or some Civil
Society problem but this is not that
this is you borrowed the money and now
am I hearing this right am I reading the
headline right yeah I mean I think
listen that's my take on it as well some
student loan borrowers are refusing to
pay out of protest uh the article says
millions of B borrowers with existing
student loans still have not made a
payment since the bills resumed in
October after a three-year Hiatus and
some admit that they're refusing to pay
for spite like strictly out of
prot in an intelligent.com survey
conducted this month a th000 federal
student loan borrowers 25% of those
people said that they had not made any
payments at all and 9% of that 25% said
that they were holding off on paying
their bills intentionally in an effort
to pressure the government into
cancelling their debt that's going to
work oh man 44% said they believe their
protests will lead to cancellation of
some federal student loan debt and 28%
think that it is likely that this
boycott will convince the government to
cancel all student loan debt you know
that's like me believing if I commit a
leg day that I'll be able to dunk a
basketball it's not going to happen
listen I don't have the fast twitch I
don't care what I do I can't dunk a
basketball when I hear what is happening
I only hear it in a whiny voice I only
hear it in the voice of my
three-year-old when she doesn't get her
way and because here like it's time to
Let It Go like can we just Let It Go
guys let it go let it go right now go
like it's time to let it go and finally
accept the fact that these student loans
are here but I understand let me just
say Ken I understand why people are
starting to feel like maybe there's a
way like you remember on Dumb and Dumber
and so you're saying there's a chance
one in a million yeah and that what's
happening is this Administration does
keep kind of dropping these little
breadcrumbs of of forgiveness that is
making people feel like maybe there's a
a chance like I know earlier this month
Biden did a great Point yeah bid that
was dangled for well over a year it's
still being dangled like Biden just did
another one that says that they're going
to forgive uh people who have $112,000
or less of student loans that's the
headline but the underlying part says
and they've been paying for 10 years
already I'm like if you if you have
$122,000 of student loans and you have
not it's taken you over 10 years and you
still haven't paid them off there's
something wrong with you not the
government at that point just throwing
that out there because you can do that
with instacart yeah like you can pay off
a $12,000 student loan in one year with
instacart so don't you got to show me
how to set up an instacart on the
commercial break listen I hear a lot
about it the problem is people are
thinking to themselves I can get away
with just not paying my student loan
like if I don't want to pay it I'm just
not going to pay it I think I'm going to
try this with my taxes this year I'm
going to tell my accountant that I'm
protesting in hopes that the IRS will
see the error of their way ways I think
it's that ridiculous I think it's the
same level of ridiculousness but they're
they're only this is the perfect
situation where we apply that adage of
like it's drinking poison and expecting
the other person to die because the
government they're the government is in
their office with their feet up on the
table eating a ham sandwich while you're
destroying your credit you're making it
hard next to impossible for you to ever
buy a house you're setting yourself up
for them to garnish your wages okay that
I'm glad you're talking about this cuz
the real reel is what how long does this
protest last before they start cracking
on them well you know the first thing
that happens is like when you don't pay
your bill it's like okay you're late
you're you're and then it goes into
there's fees 6% in some cases then you
go into default and if you stay in
default for long enough then you go from
owing what you what your missed payments
were to owing the entire balance right
right up front like it it it escalates
very quickly and what happens there is
when that takes place it's like all
right you're not going to be able to
ever qualify not that I think that you
need to but you take yourself out of the
the running to ever qualify for any
payments forbearance deferment ever
again because you've pooo pooed on it
and said you know you've basically given
the government the finger and so at that
point you've you've truly screwed
yourselves in many ways and I'm like can
you imagine you go to work and you don't
even get your paycheck because they're
able to garnish a certain percentage of
your paycheck that's what people don't
realize yeah they can take your they can
hold your passport you know what and
while you're protesting while you're
protesting they can do those things to
you and the thing is you think that
these people are losing sleep over this
in the government they don't care about
that they don't care about you fact they
make you a poster child for vengeance
listen I'm telling you there's nothing
you know that old phrase is how's it go
uh there nothing like a scorned woman
what's that I messed that up it's
something along the lines something
about a woman scorned a woman scorned
let me tell you what's worse than a
scorned woman a scorned bureaucrat oh
gosh I'm telling you you take an a DC
Insider they're all about regulation uh
you hack them off that's it they're
coming for you I promise you right now
listen there is no protest there's no
Pro it's over it's over like I just need
people to understand it's over and I do
want to appeal to some folks because I I
get it people people feel cheated K and
that's they feel lied to they feel lied
to and they feel like they they're owed
something and I totally get that like
anybody who's had student loans feels
that you feel like hey I did what my
parents told me I did what everybody
told me and now here I am I shouldn't
have to deal with this alone and I just
want to remind you that you can't blame
your way to a better life you have to
start working and pushing your way out
of that because otherwise you're just
going to stay there you're going to get
resentful you're going to you just
become Faded
Glory I like that I got a question for
you it's like when you were good at you
were good at high school basketball like
you were good at basketball in middle
school and people you just keep reliving
it and keep replaying it's like Let It
Go man like right now you're loser nowup
that's exactly why I don't play pickup
at lifetime cuz I The Glory Days are so
far gone that I I can't even remember
them all right now I have a question for
you okay because I think you make a very
good point that these people feel lied
to and okay but what how should those
people feel that way when you got people
like me and my wife who paid off our
student loans and let me give you one
other demographic the youngsters that
are signing up for student loans as we
speak well everybody feels like they're
the exception Ken and I get that some
people some people are like listen I
signed for my loans I know I signed for
my loans I knew I knew it was going to
be 60,000 and I I understood other folks
feel like listen my parents signed for
these loans I never really understood
some people feel like they didn't never
they were never taught how interest
works when they were 18 there are true
and valid reasons to feel cheated and I
never want to take that away but the
fact of the matter is you may never get
that apology you may never get somebody
giving you what they owe you that is
just a tough and hard reality of life
and then you have to look back on
yourself and go okay what am I going to
do about it am I going to wait for
somebody to take responsibility in my
life for my life or am I just going to
go you know what you screwed me that
wasn't right but I'm going to go ahead
and clean up my life because I'm not
waiting around for the likes of you
government to do what I can do myself
and that's really just the attitude that
I want people to take on for themselves
all right and we know that it can be
done like we see it every day I I gave
you the shot you did a great job I'm
going to be a little bit uh angrier
about it all right I'm tired of the
fairness Doctrine I'm tired of the fair
crap let me tell you a why for those of
you out there who don't think it's fair
that Uncle Joe didn't come through let
me tell you about Fair it's not fair
that I paid my student loan off and you
thought you weren't going to have to pay
yours off let me tell you what else it's
also not fair that a that a a whole host
of young people every year has had to
sign up for student loans it's not fair
that they have to pay and that I had to
pay and you snowflake don't have to pay
I'm sick of fair life isn't fair life is
hard life sucks life can be great on the
other side of hard and suck you know how
I know cuz I've had it hard and I've had
the suck and my life is great right now
around the world I'm tired of fair life
isn't fair you little snowflake get
inside or you're going to melt this is
the Ramy
[Music]
show
hey guys ramsy Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
netw Suite it works for us and it'll
help your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting and analytics
and supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay netw Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist list designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number for you to jump in to get some
advice about your money your work and
your relationships is 8825 5225 8825
5225 Minneapolis Minnesota is where
Craig is joining us Craig how can we
help hey thanks for taking my call you
bet what's going on so I've got a
question about contributing toward um
educational expenses for U my kids and
I've got it kind of need some advice on
two different sides so um I divorced in
2020 um and sort of Le really leaned
into the Ramy principles that was able
to pay off uh 80 to 90,000 of debt way
to go um and I'm sitting in in a much
better U situation financially so um
from my first marriage I had uh four
children and then I remarried last year
to woman um with two children from her
pre previous marriage wow um as it
relates as it relates to educational
expenses um her children um should have
their education covered one because my
wife was in the military and because she
didn't use her educational funds her
mother sort of WRA that over and put
that into her daughter's name so so that
that covers that side so on my for on
the on my four kids um there is no
saving uh there is there's nothing for
them U they're you know 16 148 and six
so kind of feeling a little pressure on
that I'd like to start doing something I
have a really good income I'm about 160
okay um my my ex-wife has a very similar
to maybe even slightly higher income
than I do okay
what but has not followed any of the
same principles which led to trouble in
our marriage and all this other stuff so
she doesn't have her debt paid off she
doesn't have all this other stuff she
spending like she's in Congress and new
boats and campers and blah blah blah
blah blah right so so a should I even
approach her to say hey I'd really like
to do something for the
kids knowing that she's probably gonna
say hey I can't do that because I have
my own stuff to pay for and if I choose
to want to do something for my kids how
do I not have resent resentment toward
her that she's spending her money having
fun and I'm trying to better the future
of the children why would you care if
your ex-wife resents you because you're
putting money on no he's saying him
resenting her oh I misunderstood I
apologize me me having resentful toward
her is that you know I'm
sacrificing to better them and she gets
to be the fun parent and do all the
trips and well you got to rise above
that yeah
yeah and and there'ss that's that's
going to come out in the wash though
like as they get older they're going to
see the reality of what's really go
going on here right now they're young
and they don't know the difference but
just trust me that'll come out in the
wash what I would say is it can't hurt
to go to her and say listen I'm thinking
about the kids college here's what I'm
thinking about doing is there anything
that you'd like to contribute if she
says yes take what you can get if she
says no then move on you know dust dust
dust It Off off your shoulders and keep
rolling and don't even really give it
another second thought um and feel good
about the fact that you are doing what's
right and you are providing for your
kids uh let's talk about let's just talk
about what that looks like on your end
since you're most likely going to be the
one providing the most if not all so
what could that look like you said that
you've paid off 990,000 of debt is that
all your debt gone or do you still have
some to go no I I'm I'm free and clear
okay perfect and do you have some
savings for yourself 3 to six months got
I've got I've got three to six months
expenses my you know last year we we we
bought a new a new to a vehicle for my
wife okay you know we have a net wor
worth probably in that6 to 700,000 range
we're just for for clarity we're 37 and
39 okay um so I mean we're we're in a
better spot and are you investing 15%
towards retirement yeah both of us both
of us are investing 15% okay so here's a
deal you got a 16-year-old is too late
for the 529 the 16 you're not going to
be able to do enough for it to matter
what was the second age 14 14 yeah
you're kind of in that situation there
so you're looking at scholarships and
and cash flowing and all that so now
you're looking at the youngsters and it
comes down to what Jade the line item
and what he can actually do each month
yeah and for the Litt I just want to
make sure it sounds like you and your
current wife are on the same page with
money like is it just you putting your
income have you or are you guys in
agreement that we're both paying for
this
yeah we're I mean so that's that's where
it gets in so like we've combined
everything together we're you know
living as one we we have sort of a
different mindset as it relates to kind
of how how life works with money and
kids and everything else because while
she had a a a family that had a lot of
money they were very controlling with it
so like she has this sort
of negative side Viewpoint of money
where I'm like money is opportunity and
everything else so I mean it's it's like
like she has a hard time with me saying
Hey I want to pay for my son's car
insurance you know okay she like she
just has that like she feels like they
need to make their own way is that what
you're saying a little bit and and I
mean my my my 16y 16-year-old Works 14
hours a week you know on top of school
and everything so like he's making money
but he has you know he has a life and a
girlfriend and everything else but so
kind of where we where we where we
struggle a little bit is is because I
make 4X her income I make 160 she makes
40 she already feels sort of inferior
with money so like when I'm trying to do
things and and trying to make smart
financial decisions she feels like I'm
taking the taking the Reigns and because
it's my money then it's then it's my
decision Craig you guys need a you need
a marriage counselor Craig Craig listen
to me you guys need a marriage counselor
you guys got to get on the same page
with this stuff she's dragging baggage
in you got
baggage yeah I agree I mean I give the
financial advice but I just have to say
that I think that I can tell you what I
think numbers wise um but I I truly
believe agree with Ken and that's normal
like I we're not saying that in a like
you need counseling like listen I'm I go
to counseling everybody needs everybody
needs counseling um so we're just saying
that in a in a way that it's easier to
just iron this stuff out when you have a
mediator there and that they can kind of
have unbiased view of what's going on it
really does help because I do think that
especially in this conversation because
it does involve kids college and they're
going to be able to look back on this
and say what am I what did my mom and
stepmom do you don't you want to feel
like you're entering that on one Accord
so there's no
unintentional negativity that the kids
feel as to how their college is being
paid for or anything like that so that
being said I do think that you need to
start planning for this now and starting
to set aside money now um out of the
budget however it is that you guys
budget your money now I hope that you
get it on one Accord but for now just
start putting that that money aside and
um you guys do need to get on the same
page with this sooner than later because
I think it's going to make it um the the
deeper you get into this if you don't
deal with it it's going to start
erupting even more and causing right now
it's kind of bubbling underneath the
surface because nobody's in college yet
but when that day comes you're going to
start to feel it if you don't deal with
it now that's right and I I am I'm
actually I'm actually less concerned
with you feeling resentment toward your
ex now I'm starting to worry about
resentment towards your current wife I
age that's what I'm concerned about and
that's the one that's more important um
because you guys are joint you're on
this new life and I think I think Jade's
right I'd get control of this now this
is not an emergency it's not a fire but
she's got some trauma over money let's
just be honest and that's not her fault
she comes from a controlling family yeah
so I do think that you guys having a
healthy conversation with the therapist
like Jade said I think that's going to
be huge because you are feeling this
pressure and and this duty to fund your
kids and if she if you feel in any way
that she's holding that up that's not
good yeah I agree and he also needs to
start thinking through with himself and
bring the the wife into this
conversation what it is going to look
like for the kids college are you
planning on paying a full way for all
four kids are you planning to do half
and half like start coming up with
realistically what the financial plan
can be and you need to start talking to
the 16-year-old about it now if you're
saying to him listen I'm not you know
this is my max amount that I'm putting
in you need to have a state school at
the very least start having those
conversations about the expectation so
that when the time comes there's no I
didn't know that or you never said that
or I just assumed you don't want that so
really be clear about what the situation
is going to be no one said that you have
to pay a kids whole way through college
let me make that clear great stuff she's
Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman don't move
more than Ry show coming right
[Music]
[Applause]
up
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me the phone
number for you to jump in for your
coaching call Isle 8825 5225 888 825
5225 Jade you got something speaking of
coaching calls Ken we are doing
something that's never before been done
this is a brand new idea that we have um
and it starts next week Tuesday January
30th we are going to do a Ramsay show
after hours situation where we are going
to stay after the ramsy show like you
know we broadcast three hours every day
who's we am I invited to this not this
one ain't you Ken this one is a feeling
I wasn't invited I never get invited to
these things is me and George camel with
a K we are going to stay after and
answer all your questions about
budgeting and not only are we going to
answer questions but we're literally
going to have every dollar which is the
world's best budgeting app we're going
to have it pulled up and we're literally
whatever the question is we're going to
exactly show you how to do not really a
demo we're just going to like if
somebody pulls up and like listen how am
I supposed to do Sinking funds we're
going to show them how to do Sinking
funds if they're like you know I I don't
have enough money in my budget what can
I do you know should I we're going to
show them how if they make an extra $500
how it's going to affect their budget
show them long-term planning like we're
going to show them Financial road map
all of that stuff and so it's very
interactive it's going to be very fun
it's going to be for an hour again the
first one is Tuesday January 30th it's
right after the ramsy show so 5:00 P
p.m. central Time and if you're watching
on YouTube which is the best way you can
even call in like it's you can put your
questions in the chat you can call in
there's going to be somebody feeding us
the questions and I think it's going to
be awesome it's real time sounds fun
yeah sounds fun very helpful by the way
yes and you're going to do it in every
dollar yes yeah by showing them how
simple it is okay good so you'll see
you'll see us on the screen and then
you'll see every dollar right there so
you're there's no no excuses hit the
sign up details one more time I think it
be good well you don't have to sign up
you just have to be there it's Tuesday
January 30th and it's right after the
show so just go on to our YouTube
channel get to the YouTube channel for
the Ramy show and you'll see it on there
as live all right uh book it folks make
the appointment it's free I love it
let's go to Greg now in Chambersburg
Pennsylvania Greg how can we
help how you doing guys you guys are
awesome thank you you too what's going
just want to say thank you um yes um
I've taken your course probably a couple
years ago me and my wife and uh we got
like $90,000 paid off in two years well
well basically we fell off the wagon I
got a settlement from an accident we'
made some stupid decisions now we're
back in the debt about
$55,000 wait a minute wa a minut we
bought time time share wait a
minute all kinds of stupid stuff well
was it
we yeah it it was we I'll take some
credit for it too how do you well tell
us what happens where you pay off 90,000
and all that hard work settlement and
then you decide to just start borrowing
again what's what going on I I just I
don't know we just we just got away from
it I guess maybe having that kind of
money just got got to a little bit maybe
M more problem how much was the
settlement
basically uh it was 40 like 40 s like 42
43,000 wow okay and and basically now
I'm I'm my wife just recently we need to
get back on the budget we need to get
back on the budget I was like you know
what if you want to go full force and do
this then yes yes I'm all in okay and
and B okay go ahead I'm sorry no I'm I'm
with you I'm like if you're going to do
this full force let's do it I just want
to make sure that we figure out what it
was that caused you to pay $90,000 off
and get a windfall of over
$40,000 and somehow end up in $55,000 of
debt like that there is something I wish
Dr John deloney was here to help us
uncover but I want to make sure that I
want you to listen I want you to go ham
and pay off this debt again but more
than that want to make sure we get to
the bottom of how the heck this happened
right oh I I totally agree but I I
suggested to my wife that we sell her
car carvana will give her
25k okay and put my truck in it because
it's $672 a month on a payment okay I
want to try to I want to try to
eliminate that but it's basically and
get rid of the time share obviously but
it's hard to convince her to to be on
board with all that she's down with you
know
I don't know and that's that that I
don't know is the most important thing
in this entire equation because we got
to know because you can't you can try to
do this alone but it's not the right way
to do it and it won't last because she's
going to keep putting you guys in debt
so and and that's what basically my
question is what is your all suggestion
am I am I wrong for asking this no I
think that I just I don't know what to
do you've had a moment you've hit on
your own on your own accord you've hit
that I've had it moment of wait a minute
like we we're going in the wrong
direction look at our life and you on
your own have had that self-realization
moment she hasn't had it yet so yeah I
don't know I mean basically she says you
know it's time it's it's time for us to
be on I mean to be on the budget but I
don't think she wants to be full force I
think she wants to just why do you say
that here and
there because she don't want to get her
the time share she don't want to you
know she don't want to I guess maybe
drive a lesser of a vehicle she wants to
be on a budget
so that she can manage the debt she just
wants to manage the money going forward
but she doesn't want to have to give up
anything in order to do it that's
exactly right oh maybe that's what it is
I don't yeah she's she's being listen no
I I don't buy it Greg you do know she's
she you know what's going she's being a
princess 100% she doesn't want to be
responsible she wants all the benefits
and you guys got a little bit of money
and you were able to flossa a little bit
and show it off and she doesn't want
want anybody to see you guys go in the
other direction I got to call Spade to
Spade on that and that's what I think it
is I think that she's more
concerned this is just me based on what
you said it sounds like she's more
concerned on how it will feel and how it
will look than what you guys will gain
from doing this that's exactly what what
it is and I'm I'm not trying I'm not
trying to bash
her for a lot of stuff too you know what
I mean some stupid this is a marriage
issue at this point mhm cuz what where
this goes is this begins to divide you
too and I listen I I'm not saying that
this is a five alarm
fire uh but this is a marriage
conversation to say to her here's how I
feel see don't make it about her make it
about you here's how I feel here's what
this debt does to me here's what these
payments do to me walk her through it
this is how I feel do you feel this way
like maybe ask some questions after you
tell her how you feel and say how do you
feel about how I feel yeah cuz I think
we got to get all the feelings out on
the table so that we know what we're
dealing with and this may be a uh I
think it's at least a couple of sesss
with a good marriage therapist to kind
of walk you all through how you're
seeing things differently and and you
both share your emotions on this and
let's see where she's at on this cuz
maybe you haven't framed it the right
way I don't know well I'll frame let me
let me do I'm going to do Greg favor
because there's certain things that Greg
can't say or he'll be you know rip right
but I can say it because I like this I'm
here there comes a point in time where
we have to become adults and we have to
act like adults and the child inside of
us kicks and screams and wants what they
want but let me tell you something if I
went to Sam warshaw my spouse and I said
listen we're wilding out right now we
paid off $90,000 and somehow we're in
$55,000 of debt it's time for us to act
like adults and sell our stuff if he
said well I don't want to do this and I
don't want I want to keep my car though
I would be like boss up and sell your
car and that's what I'm telling your
wife it's time M that you get on the
same page you got to sell your car mama
like you got to give it up and I know
that your friends are going to see it I
know you're not going to be able to go
to the Panhandle and have your weekend
you know vacations and your time share
but you you got to boss up and you got
do this the right way and your husband
wants this and he loves you yeah I say
because it's worn me out I mean I've had
to pick up a second job and all that you
know what I mean so I'm working from sun
up to sun down so it's kind of
exhausting and that's where I'm kind of
at I'm exha Greg she's got a how you
feel too Jade's right but you got to say
cuz if she wants to be married to you
then this will be a wakeup call MH
that's the reality cuz you won't be able
to go on like this forever yeah wow po
guy Greg's working sun up to sundown
Working Day and
Night Greg's afraid to put his foot down
he's and it's not that he's it's not
like a man versus woman thing it's we're
adults mhm we're adults do adult things
great hour uncomfortable great hour Jade
warshaw always great to be with you want
to thank James Charles and the crew
behind the glass to keep us on the air
and thank you America for listening this
is your show this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and in your relationships the phone
number is
8825 5225 that's 8825
5225 I'm Kim Coleman My Fabulous
colleague and friend Jade warshaw joins
me our money expert this hour I'll help
in any areas of work and pipe in and we
both weigh in on all the issues here
that you've got before you here's what
we know you can win because there's a
clear path and we want to help you see
what that is all right let's get to the
phones New Orleans Louisiana man it just
makes me crave a little cinjun a little
bit of Cajun food I don't know why PoBoy
yeah oh that's very nice Louis or Louie
how do we say it uh Louis sir thank you
Lewis excellent how can we help um yes
sir yeah appreciate you guys for taking
my call just want to start with that so
I'm actually calling in on behalf of my
mom um about four or five months ago she
was just completely misinformed about
bankruptcy we don't have like really no
Financial like I I just started
listening to Dave Ramsey about a week
ago and been learning a lot so good she
was she was um misinformed about
bankruptcy with the info she got she was
convinced that that was going to be her
best option for her situation but what
she didn't realize is that when she went
to go see the lawyer he basically let
her know that she has to sell her house
which basically caused her to have like
a mental breakdown and immediately she
looked for option b um a little break
down like so like my mom's all about
just family um other than like human
beings her house is like the most
important thing to her out of anything
um my mom and dad actually like built
that house with their own hands oh man
my dad passed away in like 2010 but the
house was built in 2005 so like she
can't like she would never like sell a
house that's not like that she would
never do that yeah so it kind of so with
that four or five months she was kind of
like because she thought that that's
what she was going to do it kind of led
her to like you know she did like Home
Improvements and like had dinner work
she did some things that she would have
never did had she not thought that would
be wiped away if that makes sense yeah
so where how where is she now like the
bankruptcy is taken place they've sold
off her assets what's what no no no so
she didn't so she she found out about it
and she just left she didn't do the
bankruptcy she just left like she had
she she she she she didn't go through
with the bankruptcy so now we're kind of
looking for option b which kind of so
they didn't sell the house no she never
um did nothing with the she went to see
how it work and then they told her all
right well you have this and this and
this
definitely make you sell your house and
then once she heard that her heart Dro
and she she was out of there so
nothing's happened yet nothing's
happened yet other than me reading The
Total Money Makeover and trying to like
beat everything in our heads good okay
good good good um good keep going all
right so kind of where she's at um you
know I've been watching the show I kind
of have an idea what y'all ask for um so
her Consumer Debt which is the only debt
she has other than the mortgage is
100,000 okay okay can you break it down
the mortgage um it's just all credit
cards 100K all credit cards different
credit cards but just credit cards only
okay this is a course of like you know
like you know leading up to this last
four months she had probably like a 700
credit score so obviously she could get
credit anytime that's what she would do
she would help people let her family go
on vacations Mom I need to borrow this
but now she's deeply in debt because of
it exactly so what kind of income
situation what kind of
income she makes about 4K a month like
she brings home 4,000 a month okay okay
she has about 26,000 in cash save she
also has like another 9,000 in Bitcoin
that she could liquidate okay she has
retirement for work she has no student
loans no other debt she has three
vehicles paid off completely can do you
know each of those cars are
worth um so she has a slingshot that's
probably worth about 16,000 she has a
Corvette that's probably worth about 10
to 12,000 and then she has like her
everyday like Yukon truck that I think
she bought it for like 6,000 like last
year or something okay that's the three
vehicles and that's her that's her daily
driver the third one the third one is
kind of like you know the car she uses
my mom's a school bus driver so she
really she really don't she just needs
one car like so my mom's one of those
people when I listen to the book she's
like she don't want to like you know
that whole don't want to give up all the
things I have to really do what you got
to do like I know what she needs to do
as far as like she should definitely
sell a swingshot sell a Corvette but she
rather like she's like you know it's
only 8,000 like that's not a big deal no
it is cuz when we're looking at it she's
got
$35,000 of money she can get a hold of
the Cash Plus the Bitcoin if she sells
it off then she's got these vehicles
34,000 in vehicles listen that's
$7,000 right there exactly and if she
does that now she only has $30,000 of
credit card debt with her income which
suddenly this becomes a quote un more
normal situation and a a much more easy
to tackle situation here's here's what I
want you to understand um number one
you're a good son like you're great and
you get it you like there's no argument
from you I can tell um so the person
we've got to get on board here is your
mom and so we can tell like I can sit
here and tell you listen make sure she
sells these vehicles make sure she Li
liquidates that Bitcoin you know make
sure she pays off this debt keep a
$1,000 aside but you know all that the
question is when you come to her with
this is she going to do it and what are
you going to do if she says
no um so basically like like I said this
is my mom she done a lot for me so um
given the fact that like how I know she
is um that kind of like Le like so
basically what I'm doing to help my mom
like I I don't have a house or nothing I
just like rent like my bills are like
1,700 for like my monthly expenses for
my house right okay my mom's expenses at
her house are probably like about 2,200
okay okay so next month like starting
March my family's like my mom has a
really like nice size house and she's
the only person that lives in the house
like it's a five bedroom house please
don't tell me you're about to move into
this house that's what it sounds like
and that you're gonna pay that
bill right so like I'm moving into my
mom's house yes so I'm moving into my
mom's house and basically I'm GNA just
instead of paying like the landlord that
I have right now my rent and stuff no
nope nope I got to put my foot down if
you're calling uh Lewis and asking us
honestly what to do it's not this your
mom I I know you love her and she's the
most wonderful woman in the world to you
and she is and she should be but it
doesn't take none of that takes away
from the fact that she's an adult and
she has she is um made these choices
she's not disabled you know she she's
not without mental function she knew
what she was doing and she made those
choices and it's very hard for us as
kids to accept that we want to say well
they needed me and no they were grown
and if you move in you're getting
yourself Tangled Up in a way that you
don't need to get tangled and you're
going to end up setting your personal
family back trying to fix your mom's
financial situation give her the
information do your you know you've been
a good son keep being a good son give
her that information but also understand
you cannot make her do this and you
inserting yourself in her life is only
going to make it worse for both of you
it's called
enabling this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
a
welcome back to the Ramsey Show Jade
warshaw joins me I'm Ken Coleman we are
here for youp 8825
5225 let's go to Dallas Texas next Adam
is there Adam how can we
help how's it going how you guys doing
today we're having a blast what's going
on with
you uh everything's going good
everything's going good hey so I was
just uh calling because I uh I wanted to
get a little bit of advice so I I am
currently contributing in a 401k and a
discounted stock purchase program with
the company I work for uh but I I feel
like I kind of maxed out as much as I
can do for myself I want to kind of
figure out what I can do more uh to kind
of make my money work for me and uh sort
of set me up for the future a little bit
better okay tell us
more uh so I I'm 23 years old uh I
currently make about uh $85,000 a year
before tax okay uh I I have no debt uh
EX except for a car loan which is about
$10,000 okay uh left you haveb Lo okay I
do have debt yeah uh but no credit card
debt no mortgage or anything like that
okay uh I have $114,000 in a 401k uh and
about uh $111,000 in savings okay uh and
about uh $5,000 in that uh stock
purchase program how how familiar are
you with our baby
steps uh not too familiar I've kind of
browsed a little bit but not uh not not
too extensively okay um what's your
living situation are you renting do you
have roommates you bought
something uh so I'm renting uh all alone
uh I live in a in a studio my rent is
about $1,400 a month okay great all
right um sorry I'm just writing this
writing this down okay great so listen I
think that you're 23 like honestly for
23 I'm glad that you don't have a bunch
of debt laying around you know the
$10,000 on a car not bad I I love that
you've got some money saved I love that
you're interested in investing and
thinking about your future so very good
in way of I don't know just kind of like
the practices that you've kept so I I'm
looking at this and for me it's it's
cleaning it up and it's just making it a
little bit more neat and getting it a
little bit more organized so that
longterm it's going to serve you the
best fair enough MH MH so if I were you
if I were you my first when I look at
this I go okay I see debt and when I see
debt I immediately want to clean it up
so my first thought is let's pay off
this car you've got
$111,000 the car is$ 10,000 if I were
you today I would pay off the car
because for me debt equals risk and why
have risk when you have the cash to be
debt free and have that pce right so I
would reach over and pay off that car
loan today so when I say that what does
that make you
feel so uh I actually that that crossed
my mind a couple times but the way the
way that I was thinking about it was
okay would I rather have this money uh
in this account that you know makes
about 5% a year or would I rather have
it tied up well it's not your
money right that's that's my biggest
thought is we think it's our money but
it's not just because we're choosing not
to give somebody their money it's still
theirs like does that make sense so I do
think reframing your mind of going okay
net worth wise it's not really my money
cuz I owe it I'm just choosing to hang
on to it so it's kind of a a false sense
of
security so what I would recommend if
you are because we're going to get to
that savings point because I know you're
like listen I'm I'm earning a a nice
percentage on it what I would do is so
once you've paid off that car how much
is your car
note uh it's about $500 a month okay
suddenly that frees up $500 a month that
you can start to throw back into that
high yield savings account and build up
that savings and for real this time it's
yours you can build that up to 6 months
of expenses and think how quickly you
could do that and now you'll have 11 or
$12,000 sitting there and it will
actually be yours and you won't have a
car note I love that plan and let's keep
it going so that's Jay just walked you
through baby steps one through three
right so $1,000 in savings for
emergencies this baby step one baby step
is paying off debt smallest to largest
you've got the One debt you pay it off
quickly immediately actually as Jade
said now watch this the $500 that she
just walked you through that you're
going to start building up that
emergency fund three to six months now
all of a sudden that goes into you
investing 15% of that income and at your
age how old are you again 23 uh 23 23
you you started the question how do I
build wealth for the long term jay just
told you but you've got to own baby
steps one two three and for you you're
at baby step two you immediately in baby
step 3 the $500 car payment that you're
going well why don't I keep it it's such
a low you know that goes into your
investing your 401k plus 15% and all
that stuff and all of a sudden my friend
Jade uh paint a picture for him he's 23
I'm plugging these numbers in now you
told me that right now you've got 14,000
in your in your 401k okay and your
that's about yes that's correct so in 40
years you'll retire at 63 let's do a
annualized rate of return of I don't
know let's say let's say 8% for all the
haters all right and let's just pretend
that you're doing $500 a month every
month all right let's see what this
calculates to at boy he's going to be
EXC should I do a drum roll listen drum
roll that out when you decide to retire
at 63 years old you're gonna have $1.9
million
wow just by you just by you putting your
car payment $500 that's just the 500 on
top of your 14 that's what she did so do
you so the answer to your question is
you're maxing out your 401K what's your
max yearly contribution you're maxing
that you're going to Max it and then
you're going to invest and that's just
the $500 a month that we cleared up my
friend you're loaded you will have only
put in you will have only if you only do
the $500 over that course of time you
will have only put in2 $40,000 of your
money and it will have grown to $1.94
million and that's at 8% listen I don't
know about you Kim but I've been looking
at my annualized rate of return and it's
juicy oh I I am very excited we're we're
having our meeting next week our annual
meeting with our smart Vestor Pro the
person that we work with and it's
exciting listen Adam I don't know if you
caught that um that's if you do nothing
else that's if you do basically nothing
else so you're you're in a situation a
month that's $500 a month and all I did
here is we there's a million investment
calculators we hear Ramsey have one pull
up that investment calculator and just
plug in those numbers I put your
starting amount in 14,000 I put in 40
years because you're 23 you know most
people retire in their 60s so I put 40
years I put 8% rate of return and I said
that it compounded annually and this is
you putting in $500 a month so you can
check those numbers 1.9 Adam so the
answer question is live on less than you
make and invest very that that's the
stay out of debt yeah stay out of debt
Kill The Debt live on less than you make
and excited Adam did we answer your
question yeah you did you did um so this
is this is separate also from the the
10% that I'm this is just $500 a month
right this is separate that's not even
you at 15% we would even get your 15%
number
yeah wow showing you it yeah we're
showing you the power of the compound
interest and you can't be playing small
ball with your little interest right on
your car this a that's a joke J just
blew your mind blew your mind listen I
ble my own mind because I'm looking at
this like wow I'm excited for you it's
not even my life yeah very very good so
Adam what are you gonna do what are you
going to do when we end this phone call
in 30 seconds what are you going to do
I'm going to go ahead pay off my car
loan I think know what I'm going to go
ahead and do tell him what he's won Jade
he's won $1.9
million it's that simple though it is I
love that he literally was the example
that we tell people all the time $500
invested monthly over the course of 30
40 years you're going to be a
millionaire and in his case two
millionaire Banas it's bananas b a n a n
i can't spell it that's impressive
I tell you what I can talk live on the
air I can do all the things that one
word is the only word I'm not sure about
when I spell it on the air which I'm not
going to you did a great Joby great
advice by the way all right well we've
just helped Adam see a clear path to be
a multi-millionaire what can we help you
do call we're here don't move this is
the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me and we are
here for you taking your questions about
your money your work and your
relationships 88255 225 Noah from Kansas
City is up next Noah how can we help
hi this is um a weird question but I
just came out of trade school as a
welder I have zero debt um I'm going on
my first job here in May on an offshore
oil rig and I just don't know how to uh
split my budget up to make good
financial decisions coming through as I
get out of trade school here great hey
before Jade takes over on the budget I'm
just curious because I want America to
hear this uh what did trade school cost
you and then what is your starting uh
hourly rate or salary do you
know um so I outright paid for my trade
school and it was about 5,000 for two
years fantastic and what are you gonna
make I will make I think it was 75 grand
as an
apprentice listen ding ding all right
Jade to help this man spend that money
wisely cuz he has no debt and I just
want to say America you've been told for
decades that a college degree is the
only way to success and Noah how old are
you Noah I'm 20 years old 20 years old
he's apprenticing Jade for 75k making
more than some of these folks with their
degrees sitting on the shelf all right
wow very very good I'm just going to ask
a couple of questions because I kind of
have in my mind like offshore oil but I
don't really know like if I'm is that
like a platform in the ocean like you go
away for a couple of months and then you
come back right yeah so how this is
going to work is I'll be working s 10 to
12 hour days um for about a month
straight and then I'm off a week uh to
kind of just go and do whatever I want
on land and how far away um so you go to
the oil rig that's out of one of these
ports I'm guessing and then where do you
live in relation to where you have to
get onto the oil rig so that's the thing
uh I will be most likely living at a
hotel rooms but my company does pay for
those hotel rooms while I'm off work
just so I don't have to commute back to
Kanas to Louisiana great and back and
forth okay so and you're living on the
rig I guess until you take your off week
yep and all that's covered yep
everything's covered from food to uh
rooms to even laundry even covered wow
so on for a month off for a week and
when you're off for the week
everything's covered so yep are you
cutting all ties then are you like
listen I have an apartment I'm letting
it go that's that I mean that's what I
would do this sounds very much like I
used to work on cruise lines obviously
your work is far more dangerous but it's
the same idea you just go away and they
pay for everything and I just got rid of
my apartment I sold my car like we sold
our cars like we we offloaded a lot of
things because we didn't need them
anymore so I'm guessing you're doing the
same so I do have a actual pretty nice
truck that I have paid off already okay
good
um so that's about 20,000 sitting here
um I was living with my parents while I
went to trade school I agreed with them
they agreed with it especially if as
long as I got out of the house as soon
as I came out of trade school they were
good with it so and you're doing just
that so the question is with this truck
you know it's paid off is it going to be
in a place where it's secure and taken
care of you know it kind of feels weird
to just have it sitting in the the
parking lot of a hotel for months on end
what's what's your plan there uh
honestly as soon as I get out of trade
school here in about a month or two I'm
just going to sell it buy a little
beater be yeah dude I am liking this
situation you're going to save I am so
happy right now so much money listen my
sit's for you I mean I do you have any
money saved yet any money saved at all
I've got seven Grand sitting in savings
and then about 2,000 in checking okay so
how does he do a budget Jade when
I mean he's got some spending cash is
stacking just stacking stacking so this
is a very different kind of budget
because he has very little living
expenses yeah I mean it's great that
they're covering your living expenses
I'm sure is it to a point or is it no
matter what like you turn in a receipt
they cover it like is it a stien that
you get no no no I mean I pay for like
my car insurance I pay for like phone
bills it's just the only thing I don't
pay for is food and most I mean I'm not
even home enough to eat groceries so I
mean just kind of okay yeah but Jade
Jade asked a very good question though
Noah in that week off are you do you
have a per DM or are you just spending
whatever you want I'm steak dinner I'm
at Ruth Chris one night Morton's the
next that's what she's getting at
because that's where we got a build so
we have 150 a day per DM okay perfect so
that's probably just enough for you what
I'm doing you you have a budget just
like everybody else yours just has very
little line items which is awesome so
you're put on that budget that every
dollar budget everything you can think
of you're going to put your income at
the top and then you're going to put
your insurance whatever else you pay for
a haircut you know new new shoes
whatever those things are that you can
think of put it all on the budget but
you're just going to see a whole lot of
margin there but here's the key I don't
want it just sitting in your checking
account we're going to have a plan for
that so number one you are going to be
investing 15% every single month you're
going to stack up this savings a little
bit more let's say stack up your savings
to 25,000 I'd I'd love that for you and
then start investing 15% every time you
get a paycheck 15% goes into a Roth IRA
first and then into your 401k do they
offer you anything like that a 401k or
anything yes yes they do is there a
match uh I don't remember the number off
the top of my head okay if there is a
match your first your first contribution
would be into that account up to your
match which is probably a certain
percentage of your salary right and once
you hit that you can go and invest 7,000
into an IRA a Roth IRA and then after
that if you still have money that you're
like listen I haven't hit 15% go back to
the 401K and you should be ma honestly
you should be maxing out your 401K and a
Roth IRA like if if if that hits the
money for you but after you hit 15% if
you're like listen my next goal is to
save up at some point maybe you're not
going to want to do this again and
you're going to want to have a home so
that then you're going to just start
socking money away for a down payment
and you can do that in a high yield
savings account or if you think this has
got like a five to 10-year track record
then you can invest that money but you
my friend are about to be loaded and
this is all right and this is the this
is what's crazy the message this message
doesn't exist we're not there's no
National marketing message I know right
you know why cuz the federal government
they they don't make anything off of
Noah the college University system
doesn't make anything off of Noah come
on Ken man's going out there and he is
going to be worth what would you take a
guess if he starts at 20 I I'm so
obsessed with what you did with our last
caller can we blow Noah's mind as well
do blow wait for this watch what she's
going to do so if you're taking home
what was your take-home pay 75,000 yeah
so what do you think realistically that
you'll have to put aside like if you
wanted to put aside some money for
Investments for sure a000
I mean honestly if you guys make up a
number I can make it happen I'm pretty
easy to live with so let's just pretend
it's a th000 bucks and you said you're
21 and this is modest a00 you're 20 okay
so for 40 years you you have a z
starting amount we're going to put it
there for 40 years 8% annualized you're
putting 1,000 bucks a month let's see
what stop it what's the number stop it's
way more than I thought I see it's 3.2
million Noah Noah
now listen she put in a th000 to teach
you something you should be putting two
grand a month minimum away cuz you have
no expenses you have no expenses who
knows how long you're going to do this
double it hit the two grand put two
grand in let's say you get to two grand
cuz you have no expenses two grand a
month let's say you put two grand a
month for 40 years which you totally
will do because your income is only
going to go up okay and you have no debt
you're going to you know you might slow
down to save for a down payment but if
we put it at 2,000 6.4 Mill
million that's insane that's insane
you're at 60 years old oh I'm slow
clapping for and here's the thing we're
talking about 60 but at 50 he's still
going to be there and at 40 where's he
going to be Way Beyond everybody else
who 40 with their fancy degrees by the
way still probably in student loan debt
Noah let me tell you something I'm going
to tell you you're the American dream
cuz there's no nightmare of student loan
debt for you you sure are wow how about
that Jade y'all better play around with
these investment calculators and get
your hopes up I could do that every call
every call go Jade Jade Jade show show
them Jade I thought that was fantastic
that's crazy money great stuff all right
quick break we'll be right back this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Psalm
127:1 unless the Lord builds a house the
work of the builders is wasted unless
the Lord protects a city guarding it
with centuries will do no good our quote
from president Teddy Roosevelt Far and
Away the best prize that life has to
offer is the chance to work hard at work
worth doing o great great stuff there
all right to the phones we gole 8825
5225 San Jose California is where Luke
joins us Luke how can we
help hey how's it going so I'm in a
little bit of a pickle here um I make a
pretty decent income I'm able to save a
lot uh and I want to buy a house but the
trick is I live in California so even
the you know the worst house in the
neighborhood around where I live is
going to be uh you know about
$600,000 or more uh what does that get
you by talk how big what's that how big
is that house uh maybe I mean it's
probably
1,500 square F feet goodness gra wow
wow yeah and even though I make a pretty
good income and I'm able to save uh it's
just feels like the goal of owning a
home is so far away especially if I want
to go the route of doing the 15year fix
rate mortgage only I'm 28 years old 28
are you single or
married uh I'm engaged engaged when's
the big day in September does she
work she does work she's a small
business owner uh but she just started
her business so little setback uh in
terms of what she had to invest in the
business will okay what will be your
combined
income uh this year I would estimate
probably aund
and 70,000
okay listen you know I'm thinking about
this situation I think everybody wants
to own a home and yours is a situation
where you've got to just like John
deloney would say Dr John delone you
have to face reality and when you look
at your situation you have to ask
yourself okay what what do we want we
want to purchase a home what in reality
can we afford a $600,000 home and if
right now obviously the answer is no how
long will it take for us to afford a
$600,000 home and are we happy with the
fact that $600,000 only gets us500 ft
like you have to to really honestly make
a checklist and I would make a list of
those questions and I would write down
my answers because there's something
about seeing it on paper versus it
floating around in the air above your
head and when you see it on paper I
think that it can help you go okay do I
want to stay in this area what what
really what gets us to the life that we
want because I can tell you like I
remember my sister-in-law they lived in
California and la for the longest and
she was a school teacher and he worked
uh I think at Nintendo and they were
like listen we're never going to have
the house and the life that we want out
here we just can't afford it and we love
our careers and they moved to North
Carolina or they moved to you know North
Florida later on and I'm like listen
that's the choice they made when they
saw their life on paper and I would
suggest you do that
because that's really what we're looking
at like I of course I'm going to say
yeah save for a down payment try to get
20% down you know buy a house where that
you know the payment's no more than 25%
of your take-home and you've got to look
at that and go is that possible with my
income where I live yes that's the
question Luke that's beautiful Jade
that's that's the issue like you guys
move anywhere else in the country and
all of a sudden this is not daunting
yeah I think with my current income to
get to the uh 15% of my or sorry 25% of
my take-home pay I'd have to have a
maybe a $400,000 down payment on that uh
$600,000 so let's run this out like Jade
just laid this out for you how long
would it take you to save up
$400,000 it' probably take um I don't
know 10 years yeah so now you're 38 so
how's San Jose feeling for
you well I don't even like uh the the
area that really because my family lives
here I want to be around them well those
are the that's these are the decisions
you have to kind of weigh those pros and
cons because we want we all want to have
it all like that's just and I'm not
saying that that's a wrong wrong or bad
or anything like that but again in the
in the vein of reality there is going to
be part of you that goes which do I want
more to live near my family or to be
able to have a home that we can afford
is there something that we can meet in
the middle cuz it's not to say that you
have to move on the other coast you know
and move to North Carolina but maybe
maybe I go to Utah maybe I go to n you
know one of these other states where
maybe I can find something where I can
still see my family on a regular basis
maybe it's a six- hour drive or an 8
hour drive but I won't lie to you th
those are tough decisions to make but
they they do have to be made otherwise
you're going to look up and you're going
to be spinning your wheels and like I
never moved forward why didn't I move
forward it's because you never made that
tough decision and if you decide hey I
want to be by F by my family then you're
also choosing something which is you're
going to live in a very small
home yeah and waiting 10 years I would
like to buy sooner but that's not so bad
what waiting 10 years
great great listen that's not bad either
or wrong if you want to stay in San Jose
then that has determined so it's like
it's look looking 30 years down the line
and now we come back we work backwards
into what is it going to take to have
this life in 30 years so if you're in
San Jose and you don't want to have be
been massive amount of debt and good
grief why would anyone settle for the
norm which is to pay 600,000 for, 1500
square feet such a bad value proposition
it's crazy I would never just accept the
norm for a bad exchange I agree I'm
always going to let value Drive what I
think should be normal and I get to
determine value and so if you're willing
to wait great but uh listen I I I don't
know what that's like Jade because to be
fair I never one time thought for a
second when I was young about staying
near my family I was just thinking the
same thing was literally you know as I
say stroking my beard thinking what must
it be like to be willing to wait 10
years in order to live by your family CU
like how do I get out yeah no chance I'm
just kidding I love my family but you
know y I do too but neither so we're
wired the same way I I feels like you
and I made the big decisions absent of
whether it was near family or not and if
it was if it was a big decision and
somehow family was near okay bonus yeah
bonus like I moved here to Nashville it
just so happened that my parents live
here that was a bonus I wasn't like I
have to live move to Nashville cuz I
have to live near my well you had
already started and led an amazing life
a long way away
so I don't know it's yeah listen if he
it's got to make sense for him if he and
his wife or they decide listen we're
we're worth we're willing to wait 10
years listen Sam and I waited 10 years
before we bought our first house so
definitely not poo pooing on that now
the the value that we the exchange for
me was worth it because the mark the way
the market was I'm like yeah I'll live
in South Florida we'll get a nice piece
of property um you know San Jose is very
different and uh you know I I he's not
wrong for wanting to wait I would still
be looking and seeing okay where can I
live that's within driving distance to
my family a 12-hour drive an a 10hour
drive I was thinking a six hour drive
three even like I'd start with a I'd
start and go okay on a map and kind of
go all right let's just look and see
it's
360° start with 3 hours that's an easy
Morning Drive
drive and start looking and go okay I
can still be very involved yeah because
I actually Wonder unless you're one of
those families and I don't know what
this is like okay yeah unless you're one
of those families that just likes being
around to each other all the time how
much do you think he's going to see his
family um even if he lives within 15
minutes listen I know families who see
each other almost daily I do yeah but I
mean do you think the average family
does that I don't but I do know that
that there's families that do that like
I wanted to ask him if is it just his
mom and dad or does he have lots of
brothers and sisters or maybe like
culturally certain families it's you're
all kind of in one home and maybe he's
the one that moved out and so he's still
trying to stay close like I get that and
by the way there's nothing wrong with
that like culturally everybody does it
different um we we're just here about
the money so we're going to tell you the
money stuff yeah and and and that's what
would drive me I'm not kidding it would
drive me to live somewhere else I would
go it's just too dagum expensive
yeah when you're buying what amounts to
a starter house yeah for $600,000 for
600 Grand yeah it's tough forget it it's
tough forget it interesting stuff great
call Luke I love your your Constitution
that you're willing to wait uh we're
challenging you to not have to wait that
long but good for you no debt man it's
going to pay off in the in the long run
Jade warshaw always fun my friend to be
uh on the show with you thank you so
much to uh James the entire crew thank
you guys for keeping us on the air and
to you America thanks for listening this
is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
yeah